a tense international stalemate in the
world of chess could end with the first
American world champion since Bobby
Fischer in the early 1970s
Fabiano Caruana it was born in Miami and
raised in Brooklyn is taking on the
world number one Magnus Carlsen of
Norway the match is tied after 12 games
and headed for winner-take-all playoff
mark Phillips is following the tents
play-by-play in London mark good morning
good morning well chest is big although
possibly not this big and it could be
getting a lot bigger if an American
upstart can beat the current undisputed
and so far invincible world champion who
has held the title for five years you
think this Chess Championship stuff
isn't serious the competitors are
electronically screened before they play
in this sport the threat isn't
performance-enhancing drugs
it's performance-enhancing
supercomputers only then can the current
world champ 27 year old Norwegian Magnus
Carlsen enter the field of play followed
by the Challenger 26 year old Fabiano
Cara Juana
who could be the first American to win a
world title since the days when chess
was less a sport and more a proxy war
between superpowers when Brooklyn's
Bobby Fischer considered brilliant if
famously eccentric challenged and beat
the Kremlin's darling Boris Spassky in
1972 there's less saber-rattling this
time according to two of Carolina's pals
who have come over to support him mr.
Spassky it was so easy for this to be
like oh this is an allegory for the Cold
War it's who has the smartest people you
know who has the biggest bombs Magnus is
just a nice Norwegian guy I don't think
anyone you know
really has problems with Norway Cara
Juana has a problem with Norway that's
who and the Challenger was under
pressure on the board the American
challenger has managed to tie Carlson
through 12 games but not beat him this
match may not be about Cold War politics
or international bragging rights but in
this world chess is more than just a
game especially if you win when Fabiano
Cara Juana talks he speaks in a kind of
chess ease I mean I don't think either
of us saw anything winning for life or
ever clearly winning for anything but he
lets his pieces do the talking on the
board where his success has produced a
Faby fan club chess is cool
chess is called nerds it's a great game
and apparently being in there it is cool
and being a winning nerd of course would
be even cooler the match now goes to the
equivalent of a sudden-death shootout
for your sports fans a series of speed
chess games where the time available
gets shorter and shorter and we should
have a either a new champion or the same
old champion
tomorrow Vienna fingers crossed that we
here yeah this is beyond oh right that's
it one even if you're not into chest
that's a very exciting thing I remember
that Magnus guy on 60 minutes when they
did a profile on him and I thought he
was very impressive but now you have to
root for a Fabiano if you live here it
cut true you know what's cutthroat it's
a brain game yeah and we're rooting for
the Americans we probably nothing
against Norway we never have problems
against Norway but we're rooting for a
Fabio I just can't wait to see the end
zone dance no idea